hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show
thanks for joining us i'm so glad you're
here
i hope you're doing well and if you're
not doing well i hope you have a
path towards being well i hope you've
got people in your life that are walking
with you
we're here to walk with you as well i'm
so glad you're here if you want to be on
the show
you want to talk about what's going on
in your life in your relationships in
your home
and your kids schools in your heart and
whatever's going on
1-844 six nine three thirty two
ninety one it's one eight four four six
nine three thirty two ninety one
or go to johndaloni.com show fill out
the form and it will go to kelly
and she will give you a shout and we
will have you on
listen i'm super excited today is a
special show
i think as a culture and you're talking
to a nerd with two phds okay
i think we have gone insane
when it comes to facts and figures
and data and more information we've
become
addicted to more data that's the way we
solve our anxiety issues and our
depression issues and our systemic
issues and
we need more data more data more data
and sometimes data is really really
important
and sometimes it's a it's the same
nonsense over and over repackaged more
fear more drama more whatever repackaged
and we were looking for quick fixes
and so one of the places i often go
when i'm trying to dig into human
problems
how do i look at marriage again in a new
way how do i look at breakups and
heartbreak and
tragedy and grief in new ways you've
heard me talk about this i
go to music i go to songwriters i go to
poets i go to fiction
right it allows me to inhabit other
people
and to experience things that i don't
have the words for or that i can read a
chart in a graph
but it doesn't it doesn't impact my
heart and my mind and my soul the way
a good song does the way a good piece of
art does the way
a great performance poetry piece does
right
the way a good book does so this is so
awesome
so the cool thing about being here in
nashville is there are
the most extraordinary songwriters on
planet earth all live here
some extraordinary poets filmmakers
authors they all live here and they just
hang out in the coffee shops man you can
walk to any coffee shop
and the cool thing about nashville is
there's no paparazzi it's against the
rules here
you walk in and everybody's a person
just like you and they're just getting
their coffee and their weird
food or whatever it is they're doing
just like you so it's awesome to run
into people to meet people and suddenly
you
look up and these people are your
friends and i'm so excited to have one
of nashville's most respected
songwriters
and guitarists and musicians
and writers folks that work behind the
scenes you may have never heard his name
but man you mention his name in this
community and everyone's like oh that
guy's the best
and he happens to also be a podcaster of
one of my favorite podcasts i don't talk
about it very often
it's so personal to me so i'm letting
that cat out of the bag i'm talking
about
andrew osanga goes by andyo andy osanga
is my friend here in town he's a a
singer-songwriter he is a guitarist who
has played carnegie hall he's traveled
the world the globe literally
playing guitar for bands and he also is
the host of a podcast called the pivot
it's one of the most important podcasts
in the world to me
it talks about the opposite of what
every other podcast talks about
most podcasts talk about here's how to
crush it and go get your dreams and how
to
his podcast talks about what happens
when you went for it you failed
what happens when you woke up and you're
35 and you're a rock star and your
leather pants don't fit anymore and you
don't have any income what do you do now
this idea of how do you change
directions midstream
and he is wise and he's smart
and he's spent many a night in tour
buses many a night with other
songwriters many a night on stage
many night behind closed doors listening
to people's hearts and minds and their
fears and their hopes
and he's an awesome dad an awesome
husband
and he's vulnerable and open and so on
today's show we talk about
what's it like when you quote unquote
make it
but your bank account doesn't reflect it
when you quote unquote make it
but you still got to deal with the fact
that you stumbled through being a dad
that day
you're kind of a crappy husband and how
do you pick yourself up how do you
change directions when life
has different plans for you than you did
right what if you do everything right
and still all falls apart
man we talk to a wise wise guy
osen is a christian guy he works a lot
of christian artists
and he also sees the messiness
that goes on behind the closed doors in
church communities and faith communities
and he just puts it all out there for us
in this awesome
interview so as always we're just going
to drop right into the middle of the
interview
there's not going to be a good start and
a good end to it it's going to drop
right in the middle of it
so i'm so glad you joined us stay tuned
for an awesome conversation with my good
friend
and world-class guitarist and
world-class songwriter andy osinga
oh man well hey andy i'm so glad you're
here and
we have a lot to talk about two big
things
first number one so before i took this
job i was working at a university
and as a part of my the way i lived my
life
it was a goal of mine
to not exist on the internet to never be
there
and i did one podcast for a friend back
in texas
awesome guy and then i swore it off i'm
never gonna do that again
and then i had like a talk with my soul
about dude you gotta be on the internets
like the world is just that way
and then i had one podcast that i
listened to religiously
and it was your show the pivot
and it was a it was something so new i
think i
ran into you and i was like oh hey i'm
john by the way i've got an idea for a
tv show and
it was the eye concept of your show was
so brilliant
and it's really what got my mind
thinking
bigger about man if you're gonna exist
in this universe in this day and age
and you want to be serious about helping
other people live a little bit
differently or you want to give people
hope
in while they're mowing the yard or in
these areas we've never been able to do
it you're gonna have to be on the
internet
and your show gave me an avenue and
tell folks about this show the genesis
of it it's so good it's so
i love every second of it tell me about
it oh man you're so kind well um
yeah first of all i remember meeting you
we were at a fireworks
show and you had just moved to town and
we had never met
dude i'm so too much too no i know this
because you were like hey
i know you and here's an idea for a tv
show for you
by the way my name is john i i know and
which was a great way to listen
i beat people up so love it i am i'm too
much
for those of you who don't listen i'm a
lot
i am it's why i live in the woods
because i meet somebody and i'm like
listen
um i've heard some records you were on
and so we're going to be best friends
i love it let's start today i love it
i'm glad we are friends oh man
uh yes you're so glad that show is
called the pivot and um
i i had uh i'd been a guitar player for
a long time musician for a long time
and then i took my first job job
at 35 years old as a working at a record
company
i did that for two years and i thought
this is where i'm going to retire this
is it this is my thing
and one day they were like hey this is
not your thing
you don't work here anymore and uh
i did not have a plan b and um
we had just gotten out of debt we i was
37 i had two
three kids and a mortgage you know or we
actually got into all the debt we paid
off all the
all the little things and um all of a
sudden i was like in free fall
and let's back up before that when
you're a guitarist yeah yeah
and you land this stage or you finally
get to play with this band or this one
guy ask your tour with them
that is the plan forever right oh yeah
cause you're all
you're gonna be millionaires you're
gonna wake up and love their pants it's
just gonna be okay
no one plays guitar for a living like
dreams of that and thinks about
when you're 34. or
when you have your third daughter on the
way right yeah no it's just you're going
to be 26
forever for eternity leather pants will
always be the right choice
right always the the most
challenging concern of a day is which
pedals to have in the pedal board right
that's always been a thing
it's still as concerned it is it's big
you're the best pedal guy no so then you
go to
job yeah which is in it which is
there's a whole thing about that of like
leaving the thing that
had been my dream and taking a job felt
like failure
uh which we that's a whole nother
conversation um
so right about the time i started to
feel comfortable as in this new world
and with who i was it was pulled out
from under me
um which just whatever they just had to
let people go and it's fine
um but uh
not knowing what to do what i found was
the next day or the next like couple
days the next couple weeks all of a
sudden the conversations i had with my
friends were different
because everybody all of a sudden i was
a safe person and everybody was like
because you were a failure
yeah and they were like dude that
happened to me too or i feel like that's
about to happen to me or i hate my job
or
i don't know what i'm doing whereas a
couple weeks ago when i had the cool job
and the office and the
top floor and everything you know like
nobody was willing to talk nobody wanted
i was not the guy you went to to talk
about that stuff uh okay so all of a
sudden i was a safe place
i mean while i've been listening to all
these podcasts that i love about people
who
you know i started southwest airlines i
did this amazing thing i did
i was listening to all these people's
successes but i was like deep in my own
failure
and uh i felt like
i need to know that other people have
been here and that it's okay
and these people were all my friends
were telling me these stories that were
so helpful
and i had free time and some microphones
in the basement
so i started and i started a podcast and
this was kind of you know it was before
everybody started a podcast it was one
of the og podcasts it kind of was
who knew um i just loved podcasts and
had free time so i started interviewing
my friends
just hey can we have a conversation
about not how you made it
but what happened when the question is
uh what did you do when life stopped
working the way it used to
and i started talk it started being
about career but eventually
you sort of pull the camera back because
career is typically a symptom
of the rest of your life you know
how is your family you know what happens
when your health fails what happens when
your family falls apart what happens
when you lose your faith
what happens when you get a faith right
you know what when something major
changes life doesn't work the way it
used to you walk in the room
you flip on the light switch and it
doesn't turn on what do you do
and that is fascinating why why do we
not
have it happens to everyone it happens
to everyone
all the time why do we not talk about
this
because it's embarrassing why because
we're ashamed
why why does it it's
it's like um the dinner
right like we're not ashamed we all eat
right we do it every day why
i you've you've just sat down with so
many people i
love love loved the idea of
what happens when the thing you thought
was gonna happen
didn't yeah right and my
work with crisis has always been you
show up when it's in a situation people
nobody thought their day was gonna end
like this yeah right or they thought
they were gonna be married to that
person forever and that person's not
there anymore
or i thought i was gonna go to my kids
graduation that kid's not there anymore
i thought this job was the next thing i
thought i was going to be 20 i love that
line i thought it was going to be 26
forever
and i just didn't have a plan after that
yeah why can we not talk about this
and so and that that's what has been so
fun and so freeing is being able to have
those conversations with people
realizing that everybody has that story
whether they're
you know some people that failure led to
the next success
some people that failure led to a bunch
more failures
yeah or uh but if you're still living
and breathing
life goes on so what do you do and how
do we how do we pursue health how do we
pursue
community how do we pursue god in
that because that's where we find those
things that's where
when we lose those when we lose our
identity when we lose the things that we
often have have idolized that's when we
have a chance
to rebuild on a better foundation if you
were just
to step back from i mean you've done
multiple seasons now of the show and
it's just
it's i can't recommend it enough i know
it feels weird to go to this show so i'm
telling you to go to someone else's
it's so good go to that um the pivot
with andy osinga
if you were to step back and say what
are a couple of commonalities that
you've experienced with folks when
things fall apart
when that record deal like you're gonna
be the guy and then it doesn't happen
yeah
yeah yeah or that show doesn't happen or
that job you got laid off or
he got cancer and passed away what's
some commonalities here
the people that handle that stuff well
are the people who have already done the
work
that's be and what i mean the work like
you can know instantly when somebody has
done the work and i mean like the work
of knowing their own story
knowing when you've already got the
sense of
my job does not define me my status does
not define me i'm defined by
how god created me and how he views me
when you
when you can operate out of that space
you're okay
you know and when you can't you fall
apart and that's
um that's the biggest thing that i've
taken away from it is you can tell
immediately
who had done that work who knew who they
were outside of
whatever it is they were changing who
was prepared for it not that you're
prepared for what
happens you're prepared for anything for
life right
yeah so so it's made me want to be that
person it's it's identified for me
places where i have not done that work
okay and that's been
really helpful and really not fun
sometimes yes
okay so um one of the most common
conversations we have on this show is
talking about
you gotta let you gotta let whatever
fantasy
and it's it's kind of uh like a thumb in
your eye way to phrase it but
i thought my marriage was gonna look
like this i thought my in-laws were
gonna treat my grandkids like this
i thought my health was going to always
be i thought we always be 26 whatever
that looks like
um there's this
so hard to make that turn yeah
right so the illusion is if i can just
get
here everything's gonna be okay right if
i can just get my husband to fill in the
blank if i can just get my kids to get
these grades or get into this school
things are gonna be fine if i can just
get this debt paid off then
if i could finally get into those pair
of pants again it's just gonna
yeah and you've gotten to experience
this in a way that is
a true fantasy for folks because you've
traveled
the globe with multi-platinum artists
you've
you've played guitar you're you're a
national i mean your national treasure
here right
um and he rolls his eyes he is if you
ask like hey who's the
best sonic texture guitarist in the city
to a hundred
people a hundred of them would say i'm
saying of course have you seen his
pedalboard
all of it and by the way he's the only
guy in nashville tennessee that's
permitted to
have these stable offenders that he has
james james's offender guy
and i'm a gibson guy to the ad i know
you are but you can have both
listen he knows what's up he's a
professional
he said it he's got both he's
switzerland but whatever that's like you
can only have
phillips head screwdrivers like yes
they're helpful but you're gonna need
some plaid that hurts
that hurts all right fair enough the
wise one
um so oh oracle that's a great analogy
with the screwdrivers and i don't have
any comebacks to that
so you've been on these stages you've
been when the ryman auditorium has sold
out you've been in front of
massive festival crowds
tell everybody what it looks like when
you quote unquote make it right
your bank account suddenly fill up you
suddenly are able to see yourself in a
new light your marriage is great you're
super apparent
like help people deconstruct that
fantasy yes i
i made the mistake uh when i got to play
carnegie hall with stephen curtis
chapman who had when i was a kid was
like my idol
right i had a poster of him on my wall
when i was 12. so i got to play
i was in his band we played carnegie
hall the first time for him
and i made the mistake of checking my
bank account right before i walked on
stage because i was holding my phone
just
like oh oh that's not the right color
[Laughter]
i didn't magically just deposit in when
you no no
um and uh yes you know the thing is is
that
what when i finally stepped away from my
career in music i was able to look at it
i mean i still do it but when i when i
stepped away for the first time thinking
i was done
when i was 35 i could and i you know
could write it on a paper i went oh that
looks like a guy who's done some stuff
but every day of that 16 years that i
was full-time doing that
just felt like a failure every day felt
like
yeah i'm i'm i'm pretty good but there's
that guy
but i didn't get that gig but that guy
got that gig would there ever be a place
is there any musicians any artists that
are like
nah i'm here i i i personally exist
there's a there's a
one of the phrases that goes around
guitar players is john mayer wants to be
eric clapton
eric clapton wants to be george harrison
george harrison wants to be paul
mccartney and paul mccartney wants to be
paul mccartney in 1964.
all right which is basically john mayer
meaning that it doesn't matter you're
always always somebody better
there's always somebody that you that
you wish you were
when when that's what you operate out of
you will never crest the wave
and so walk somebody through walking off
that stage
it because most of us will never walk on
stage at carnegie hall
right you play a show with your idol
on a stage that is magical
you step off you take off your leather
pants because clearly let's be honest
and then you go backstage you shower you
go home and you're in a hotel room by
yourself
yeah that bank account's the same yeah
yeah your marriage is the same
yeah your kids are the same except they
missed dad tonight because they just had
their routine right exactly
i just paid a babysitter yeah yeah so
walk people through what that gap in
your soul feels like
yeah the first few times it it's uh it's
it's pretty crazy you feel like you're
supposed to
you're supposed to feel fulfilled and
not like it's not like it's not a great
experience it was amazing
it was it was awesome but
yeah it ends right it's 23 hours of your
day left
right yeah and uh i've now come to
to recognize that that's the cycle that
you get the high it's a camp high that's
what it is it's a campfire okay
and you know it's fleeting and i've had
number one
songs on the radio and next week
somebody else has a number one song on
the radio like it doesn't last
and uh yeah the first few times of that
are
devastating because is it because of the
expectation
or you're caught off guard by it well
it's because you spend your whole like
when you're a kid i'm nine years old
drawing
you know drawing stages on in you know
in my notebooks and that's all i think
about and so when you do it and you
realize that's it
oh that's it that's it that's
it you know i've heard you know one of
uh
somebody says someone must say of
shakespeare
even of beethoven is this all yeah you
know
if that's if that's the end goal your
accomplishment like it's
you're never gonna you're never gonna
get it jeff bezos cannot get enough
money he has more money than anyone in
the history of the world of earth of
entire history
and it's still not enough he's got a new
plan for the next thing
right yeah because if that's what
defines you
you're out you're out of luck so when
you when you
are sitting at home listening to this or
you're driving on the road
and you think whoa okay so this guy
played carnegie hall
planned his whole life to get here got
there it's awesome
paid his debts off is it is
by all metrics because your daughters
are incredible he's a good dad
um good husband well respected in the
industry
that didn't put appeared at the end of
the sentence for andy right then
i'm backing out thinking i'm a soccer
mom i'm shuttling kids around town
if i could just fill in the blank if i
could just do this
what do you tell folks as an artist
because i i
mental health folks do their thing and
they use science and they use it
i think the beauty of art is it gets in
the soul through the back door
and it unwinds people in a way that you
feel it here
and i think that's that one of the great
tragedies of our times we've just sucked
the artistry out of so much stuff
right it's content as it i mean
it's it's the marrow of these bones
right so
what would you tell somebody is more
important than
getting on that stage oh man
i love that you asked that i so now my
primary
vocation is uh i work at a record
company in worship music
okay and i oversee a large group of
artists and songwriters and
who are 26 thinking this is going to be
26 forever right some of them yeah okay
and and my role is to help them find the
best songs
and create the best versions of those
songs to share to people
and i love it and
i talk often you know often
i will say you know when people are
stressed or frustrated or this didn't
work or they're
angry about this or you know legitimate
or not
there are a lot more janitors in the
world than there are full-time musicians
right or part-time musicians
you know most most people that i'm ever
going to run across
in my life are the lucky few
just because they live in america
because they live in this time of this
you know
2020 little snapshot of history you know
like
uh the biggest way to fight cynicism or
bitterness which is what happens
after that hollowness right after that
night where you
you get the high and then you feel the
hollowness in the hotel room
at the end of the night like what
follows is a choice between bitterness
or gratitude
and that takes intentionality
and it usually also takes community it
takes friends it takes people who can
call you
on it and say hey you know what stop
being um
you know i need to figure out what i'm
saying
but you know stop being a jerk that was
awesome
yeah congratulations now how do you how
do you keep being a good dad how can you
live in the gratitude now what what do
you do with that
you know it's not what next but it's
what do you do that you've done that how
can you how does this enable you to
serve your community better how does
this enable you to be
to love your wife better to um to be a
better neighbor better friend
and so um i think gratitude and
community are really
the antidotes for that and
that's fascinating because i think the
tendency i have is to say
well if if a stage isn't gonna help
if being a good husband isn't going to
make me feel whole then
why try and it's both and right it's
it's cool to be really good at your
craft
and be well respected in your industry
and
to recognize that's fleeting and this
doesn't define all of you right
yeah i'll say this like when i've
stopped i stopped playing music for a
living like chasing that like
i now know without beyond a shadow of a
doubt that i am not going to be a major
star as a musician okay
because i'm a certain age i've moved
into a different phase of it
i still play a lot of music around town
and work on records and write songs
and it's so much more fun for me now
because yeah i've put all the time into
it so i'm i'm decent at what i do
he's really really good uh
you're i mean it's nice to be able he
plays fenders and gibsons that's all i'm
gonna say
but it's nice to like to not have the
pressure of it to just
nice to just enjoy it right it's as fun
as it was when i was 13.
because it's i'm doing it because i love
doing it and i and
i get to learn about myself and i get to
i get to write songs that serve
my community right now um you know i
don't put out a ton of records anymore
it's they used to be every year now
they're every five years yeah
um but my my oldest daughter is 16
my next is 14 like my kids are going to
leave my house soon so
everything i've been writing this last
season this next project that i'll put
out
they're all songs for them for when they
don't live with me anymore this is what
i have to say to you
if you can't get me on the phone you can
find me on spotify this is where i'm
going to leave you
little messages and bottles of what i
have to what i what i want to say to you
and it's
and it's that god loves you pretty much
that's it
here's here's a bunch of different ways
and a bunch of different rhymes to tell
you
that god loves you and
i'm having so much fun doing it there's
so much freedom in it because i'm
literally writing all these songs for
three people
and um but i think i've told you this
i got a copy of your last new record
and i was it was 4 30 in the morning and
i was heading to a hunting trip my son's
dead asleep in the back and i put it in
and i moved the speakers up where
they're just in the
little front part of the truck
and it was so good i
almost called you to tell you i'm
driving down the highway in the
pitch black morning crying i need to
know how good this song is and then i
remember thinking
it's 4 48 we're not that good of friends
yet
i'm a lot this is too much even for me
and so i didn't say anything but i
remember just thinking how does somebody
connect this way then it's almost like
because you got you've got you're
not just creating good art bro but
you're writing up
you're writing a love letter to your to
your babies right you're writing
a love letter to grandkids you're never
going to meet um or great grandkids you
you may never know
about legacy that's something totally
different i mean it's not saying that
they're good songs but they're
but it's fun to write them you know it's
it's that's a different
level of i want to connect so that i can
make a bunch of money
or i gotta have a number one the
pressure oh dude the pressure of trying
to
you know and i've done that in in the
artist world but i've done it now i've
been in the business right side of it
for seven years and so that's long
enough to have
tried really hard to make something work
yeah and i know that that's never the
thing that works a
mm-hmm and b it's never fulfilling right
because i'm just chasing the hit
yeah and when you're trying to do the
thing that to show everybody
so that they respond to you and they
respect you and
like man that's that's never your best
it's hollow right it's never your best
work
yeah it's hollow and nobody trusts
nobody believes it
how does it how does it a a community
here how does it an
audience it's probably better than
community an audience knows
they they know you're not you
instinctively
it's got to just come through the i
don't know how that works but that you
can hear it and you just
know yeah yeah that person's not telling
the truth and for some reason same
production
same instrument same studio you just
lean back and go
yeah that guy's telling truth oh yeah
yeah
i don't know man that's one of the
that's one of the hardest things to
chase in
in what i do is how do you capture
when you know somebody and and you know
they're trying to communicate something
how do they
do it in a way that that feels true
and that that speaks to the heart of
somebody that's that magic uh gullihorn
quote like
how would you say it right like i want
to tell my
my brother that i love him how would you
just tell him like
say that right this is magic words all
right so let's back out here
you mentioned something that's um meant
a lot to me
and a community you're involved with has
reshaped this for me over the last
decade what this means and in fact it's
become something
a drama i beat all the time it's the
idea of you cannot do life without other
people
right and i'm thinking of
the the women who call the show
who have had miscarriage number three
and if they get one more text message
from their friends
about the upcoming baby shower right or
if they see one more
woman walk through the grocery store
with this new baby
how do you have community
and not hold on to that man you've got
something i don't have because it feels
very similar to
the the art the artist world you've got
buddies now who have their own names
have their own labels and their head not
on a tour and you're just got your
fingers crossed i'm gonna get that call
and then some other guitarist gets that
call yeah yeah how do you
how do you retain community how do you
retain
love with these folks and not let that
demon of jealousy take your soul from
you
oh does that make sense yes uh
i think you just described my 20s and
30s in that question
or i've always just wondered from afar
there's just a bunch of guys in a bunch
of different bands and i know
if i'm sold a million records banned
x if i invite you guys out with us i'm
gonna change
your family's financial position yeah
but i'm gonna take them
i'd have a hard time not being like dude
yeah what about this guy you know what i
mean but that's i mean that's that has
that's
every industry that's everything
everything every family is every
situation why do you have a husband that
didn't cheat on you
why do you have a kid that didn't get
leukemia i mean that's a question we ask
all the time it feels particularly acute
in your world
as almost a daily occurrence how do you
have community with folks that you're
also kind of like man i wanted that
yeah oh dude i mean that i you know
i mean i have a a couple mutual friends
of ours who have become
like i've watched i've watched a few
friends become legends
right you know like oh we were friends
and now people don't talk about you the
way they used to they talk about you the
way they talk about
paul mccartney you know and i have
followed you in the bathroom yeah and
we're the same
right i know exactly what you're capable
of right
you know what i've heard you when you're
pissed off and you know what i mean like
yeah
i know you but the whole world has said
we choose you right yeah there it goes i
mean
i think i lost i lost a number of years
to bitterness
over that uh and when i say lost i mean
i lost out of i lost out on the
relationships i could have had with
people because i was so it was so hard
for me to handle
um i'm really going for it here aren't i
uh is there a couch i can lay on
but it's but it's true you know i think
it's it's so easy
to say you know i can't even talk to
that person because it's just too hard
for me because
i want to be i think i deserve it or
they don't deserve it or whatever
it's not fair it's not fair i worked so
hard
you know especially in america i think
we have this view that if we work so
hard we can
we if we can we can achieve it we get it
you know go get your dreams kids it's
like
actually the math doesn't work out
there's only so many right
there can only be so many astronauts and
presidents yeah and that's hard
but at some point you either again
choose bitterness or gratitude
am i thankful that i get to do what i do
or am i angry that i didn't get to do
what they did
because i got to do something that's
wonderful yeah and i will never
appreciate the wonderful thing that i
did get to do
you know because i'm if i'm so focused
on
what they got instead of me and um
is that is that a discipline you forget
it's absolutely a discipline
it is a choice it is a wake up put your
feet on the ground and decide to be
grateful
every every single it's almost like
i'm gonna run every day so that the day
shows up and i've gotta
sprint i'm ready yeah and it's it gets
easier
yeah because guess what it's it's a
joyful way to live
right it's actually really fun to enjoy
the things you get to do
and it's fun to celebrate your friends
when they when wonderful things happen
to them
that has become probably the most
mind-blowing thing of the last two or
three years for me
is how problem-centric
how hey how are you man i am fine it's
code
right it's this and it's whatever and
that's just how we greet one another
it's hot it's so cold yeah we don't
greet each other with do things are
actually pretty good right now yeah you
know what i mean we don't have a
an ethos for that and this idea of being
able to celebrate
your friends that has become the way i
know
that i'm in true community with somebody
when i'm having a rough day and they
tell me something great and
i'll it's exciting to hear it and vice
versa right
yeah oh that's so beautiful though isn't
it but it is
i struggle with understanding beyond
time and
weird like we experienced some stuff
together we were on a bus for
six months ago i struggle with
articulating how to cultivate that
in just the average run of the day world
other than sitting down the gratitude
journal making
it a daily disciplined practice i mean
that's definitely you know
scripture prayer i mean i don't know if
this is can we talk about this yeah
yeah yeah you want to yeah um but that's
how you i mean that's where it is
right that's that's that's where you
find that that's where you find peace
that passes understanding
and that's what you're really talking
about is is peace instead of
anger and jealousy yeah and when you can
operate out of peace and joy
dude you can do anything yeah then you
can really
do what you you know you can achieve
your dreams because the thing that you
dream
is loving and serving other people
and when you're loving and serving other
people
have you found i mean it feels like the
more you're focused on
other folks the more stuff
i don't want to sound all j busy right
the more stuff comes at you
you know what i mean it is not jpeg you
don't you don't do it for
the roi of it you do it because you just
hold life a lot lighter
but the truth is if you're the person i
literally i just had coffee
with a like a young singer songwriter
like two hours ago
before i was here uh who's
got maybe some more resources than some
others and it's like
just it's not happening for me you know
and
i'm working all day in my house just
working on this stuff it's not happening
i was like
i think you need to invite other people
over and and and
who can you serve make a list of people
that you can serve with your resources
and your time if you've got this
you know the truth is is like you're
going to work on their stuff
you're going to get better they're going
to get opportunities they're going to
call you to be a part of it
that you serving your community
is actually going to be the best thing
you can do for your career right
but but if you but it's not to do it for
your career
it's to do it because it's the right
thing to do nothing to do right it makes
you you're
makes you a better person you get to you
get to joyfully serve these people
and the process of giving our lives away
we get so much more life like
that is true it's hard but it's simple
so let's shift gears here you have
been on the road with a number of people
over the years
gajillion i would say give or take
you've seen a lot of different
versions of what dating relationships
look like what marriages look like what
parenting looks like
my guess is you and i've never talked
about this my guess is you've
seen some and you're like probably
wouldn't do it like that or
you've seen some and been like that's
aspirational
i would love to yeah lean into it that
way
again this is a show that's i'm a dork i
went to a lot of college and so i got a
lot of clinical answers and i've
sat with people i get
so much from how art looks at
different different ways of living your
life how it informs it yeah
as an artist who has spent so many so
much time with other artists
if someone was to say hey man what are
some tips and tricks on being a great
dad
what are some tips and tricks on being a
good partner in a in a
romantic relationship what would you
what would you tell somebody
uh i mean i would say first of all
i deeply wish i was better at both of
those things yeah
um the moments where
i have felt great joy in parenting and
in husbanding um
it's like it's exactly what we just
talked about it's
um it's seeing other people and
serving other people and it's um
i remember uh we were at this thing at
one of my kids schools a couple years
ago and they said
if you really want to talk to your kids
and have like one of the best ways you
can love your kids
is to get below eye level and when
you're below eye level like
you're looking up at them and it's a it
it flips sort of in our brains how we
process
it's the power how we should trust right
and i immediately so i started
trying that and i mean dude it works
overnight yeah
but what's what what what do we all want
we want to be seen and loved we want
someone to know us
and to love us despite knowing us that's
right yes
right and to celebrate call out the good
in us
and that's what i want and so um
you know we have amazing kids i think a
lot of that's because they got great
genes from their mother
and kids are incredible yeah and
you're kind and so are yours and
but i think it's a lot of it's that you
know we spend a lot of time
together we have we have a very small
house that we've desperately tried to
get out of a few times
but it hasn't worked but i honestly
think having a small house has been
great because we have to be in each
other's business
we can't we don't have the option to
like
get away from each other so we have to
deal with it
so you have to be intentional every
second of every day yeah and uh as much
as
it'd be nice to have you know like three
bonus rooms and five guest rooms it's
like well it's
it's been kind of great to all be stuck
in this little room with each other
because
here we are here we are and that means
we're going to have to have
uncomfortable conversations
yeah we're going to have to connect with
one another but
that means also we get to experience
what's on the other side of those things
and and that's been really really fun um
and a man i think to adventure with each
other
you know and it that doesn't have to
mean a lot of money but just
explore and waste time together and
build things you know just
be creating things be side by side with
each other as opposed to across from
each other
and and working on things together um
this has been really fruitful dude
that's so good man
uh is that old rich mullins quote that
we tend to
over spiritualize jesus and i think with
parenting we tend to over
theorize it and over academize it and oh
man kids are just
desperate for like we just hang out just
can we just see me can i go with you to
the store
yeah can you ask me about my day could
we be silly on the way yeah and
can we sing and will you sneak me some
jelly beans i mean the parenting can be
really really simple yeah if i can put
my phone down and
put my desperate need for this other new
series i got to watch or this
my ambition for to be 40 and i got to
still put those leather pants back on
bro
right they say ambition bites the nails
of success doesn't it though
so last question here um
you work with a lot of young artists
right
you work with folks writing and
processing and trying to put worship
music out into the world yeah
often i think if i think of worship
music and you distill it down it's what
are the things burning
holes in people right now and when you
talk to young people
their ambitions you can kind of step
back and see what are their gods right
now
yeah so as you work with young people as
you work with trying to
that bridge to connect with audiences
when you listen to what they are
looping on what their dreams are what
their fears are
and you've got a house full of kids
right
what are a couple of things you're
seeing just out in the world
that bring you joy what a couple things
you're seeing that make you really
uncomfortable
i mean i am really blessed with an
amazing community
i believe that the best work only comes
from community
um i was really just lucky or the lord
smiled at me or whatever
to have sort of found a really great
community super early on that i'm still
super tight with and we worked together
all the time yeah you know 20 20 some
years now we've been
and all of our roles are different but
it's still the same people
um and that's been a real joy and
one of the things that's given me the
most joy is being in this position now
where i get to sort of invite people to
the table
but what i get what i do is i sort of
set the table
and then i get to back away and hope
that they become friends
and it's been fun to watch some of them
create
themselves and there's a little fomo
because i want to be in it right
because it's you know it's like oh i'm
like but i'm a coach now i'm not a
player
and um and it's been really it's been
wonderful to watch
these this community grow and one of my
uh colleagues
there's a dear friend uh he calls the
work we do relationship farming
wow you sort of plant seeds and you tend
it
but the lord's gonna make things grow
and and
i'm not if i'm chasing sort of the hit
uh
then i'm trying to i'm trying to use
people but when
when i just bring wonderful people
together and try to serve them
then they make wonderful things that
will get hits
but that's that's not the point that's a
byproduct of
that's a byproduct of it so by us
building by us trying to
to really build a healthy community of
people
that we serve well um that equips a lot
of communities
around the world you know and they'll
they'll make things that will serve
people and that's really been
beautiful what what are you hearing from
young artists from young musicians
that makes your heart skip like you only
need to solve this man
right you all need to get on this
oh man um i don't know man i just i feel
like there's a real
um i can go so deep into this and i
don't know we don't have time but
um there are these generational arcs in
the way that the church
tends to work where you had
the jesus people and then you had the
mega church and then you had the kids
that grew up in the mega church
that are the you know millennials in gen
z or gen x and they had kids
and now the young artists
and the young people are the kids of the
millennials
of like they're the grandkids of the
mega church
and uh so you're seeing an embrace
of uh of less scripted
worship less scripted interaction with
things they don't want to be programmed
or they don't want to be sold to they
don't want to be marketed to
they just want to be with huh and the
church is growing a lot smaller
among people that age and what i'm what
i mean by that is not uh in number of
people
actually but they don't want to meet in
groups of three five thousand they don't
want to be in number
they want to meet in somebody's living
room and they want to be known it's just
what we talked about the other stuff
and so uh most of the young artists that
i work with
are in deep intentional communities of
50 100
200 people they come in these small
churches and they're doing just
beautiful work because they're writing
songs
for my friend who just lost their mom
and not
to try to get on the radio gotcha right
and so when that song gets on the radio
oh man that's fun and then i hear it
driving down the road
and i just lose a buddy yeah and then
somebody
just puts a a lightning bolt into my
heart
because they're writing to somebody and
that somebody
happened to yeah look a lot like me
right yeah it's
it's so that's when you get magic man
yeah well dude i'm so grateful
that you're now the player coach the
only thing
the only challenge with that analogy is
there's got to be moments like when
you're
a coach coach like i can't jump like
that anymore i'm old my knees don't work
you have to sit there on the sidelines
sometimes be like i could play that
better than that guy
i know number one you should not be
playing a jazz master because
why is that guitar even made and two
that's an inside joke he's got one
um and two i could probably play that
better than you but i gotta let it go
let it be out there that that could be a
challenge sometimes
it's gratitude right i guess but it's
fun when they get it you help them get
it that's the fun thing
is it the awesome i just got to see you
at the ryman sitting off into the wings
to split with your gratitude journal
like i'm grateful for this opportunity
to this watching somebody just go kill
it oh that's wonderful
well brother thank you so much for being
here and what a treat we end every show
with the greatest song of all time right
before we we
started rolling by the way um we talked
about this earlier but um
your show one of your most important
songs for me
the last couple of years was one of the
first songs we we
uh i put on this show the greatest songs
ever so it's such an important song for
me
um but i asked you what's the most from
your favorite song of all time
you immediately rattled this one off we
printed it off brought it so
you can do the honor you're the first
guy to ever get to
close the show with their favorite song
goodness well we like rachel cruz but
she tanked it no
mcconaughey did his favor too so you
were in good company
dang with mcconaughey rachel cruz and
osinga
well i don't need this but um oh you oh
see look at that baller movie no
it's it's i mean it's on my it's
imprinted on my heart right that's paul
simon
who's just my favorite uh and this is
one of his later records
a couple years ago he's i love it right
now because he's not writing as a young
man he's writing as an old man yeah
and i love hearing this brilliant poet
write about
sort of regret and loss and longing and
the future it's amazing he's writing
some of the best songs ever
but uh this song i won't read the whole
thing but he goes
who's gonna love you when your looks are
gone who's gonna love you when your
looks are gone he says that a bunch of
times
and then at the end of someone goes god
will like he waters at the flowers on
the windowsill
take me i'm an ordinary player in the
key of g and my will was broken by my
pride and my vanity
who's going to love you when your looks
are gone who's going to love it when
your looks are going
dang so good that's the guy that had all
the looks
maybe for a little while for a minute
yeah wow garfunkel did
garfunke was the looks that looks kind
of like this show
you're garfunkel i'm paul and he's got
the looks hey thank you so much for
being with us hey everybody thanks for
for joining us on today's show this has
been the dr john dolone show
[Music]